hi everyone this is Professor Ram Dass
science and this is an exercises video
to learn about manipulating operators
this is another one of our videos in the
series on rigorous quantum mechanics so
why do we care about operators operators
allow us to describe physical quantities
in quantum mechanics and therefore in
order to do quantum mechanics we need to
learn about operators for example if we
want to learn about what a particle is
we need to use the position operator or
if we want to learn about the energy of
a particle we need to use the energy
operator so what I want to do in this
video is to practice manipulating
operators and we're going to do that by
looking at the adjoint operator which
allows us to connect the state space
with the dual space if you want to learn
more about state space and dual space
check the video in the description
otherwise let's go in this video I want
to work with you
deriving a number of relations to do
with the adjoint operator that will be
good practice for manipulating operators
in general let's start with a refresher
of operators and their adjoints an
operator a is an object that acts on a
cat's eye and gives another cat Sai
Prime the corresponding expression in
the dual space tells us that the adjoint
operator a dagger is the one that acts
on the corresponding drops eye and gives
the corresponding drops I prime there is
a video in the description where I
introduce the idea of operators in
quantum mechanics so check it out if you
haven't yet the first thing we want to
look at is how the matrix element of the
adjoint operator is related to the
matrix element of the original operator
all we need to prove this relation is to
use conjugation of the scalar product
that means that the bracket between Sai
Prime and Phi is equal to the bracket
between Phi and PSI prime star with the
definition of the primed heads in brass
above we can write Sai prime as psi a
dagger and Sai prime here as a PSI and
that's it we will write that a relation
we want it Sai a dagger Phi is equal to
Phi Apes I star what I want to do in the
rest of the video is to use first of all
the relation between the state space and
the dual space and second the relation
between the matrix element of the
adjoint operator and the original
operator as shown here to prove these
four relations that we have down here
for the first one we're going to use the
matrix element in red and the relation
that the adjoint of the adjoint of an
operator is equal to the original
operator to prove that we calculate the
matrix element sigh a dagger dagger Phi
we then use conjugation to get Phi a
dagger psi star with a noose conjugation
again and then taking the complex
conjugate of a number twice gives us the
original number and now we can see that
the a dagger dagger is equal to the a
here because sine Phi are arbitrary
States we're done a vago dagger is equal
to a to prove the next relation I'm
still going to use the matrix elements
between a dagger and a and the relation
tells us that a a dagger where little a
is a scalar is equal to a star a dagger
again to prove it we write Tsai a a
dagger Phi we use conjugation to write
it as Phi a Apes I star we then take the
a out we then use conjugation again and
then we bring the scalar a star back in
comparing the original expression in the
matrix element with the final expression
in the matrix element we arrive at the
solution a a dagger is equal to a star a
dagger to prove the next relation we're
still going to use the matrix element
between a tiger and a and the relation
is that a plus B dagger is equal to a
dagger plus B dagger we start in the
same way sigh a plus B dagger Phi we
then use conjugation we then separate
this expression into Phi Apes I star
plus Phi beeps I star we then use
conjugation again and then we bring them
back together to right beside a dagger
plus B dagger Phi comparing the middle
of the matrix element here to this one
we obtain the final expression A plus B
dagger is equal to a dagger plus B
dagger the final relation we want to
prove will actually be proved by using
the relationship between state space and
dual space shown here and the relation
tells us that the adjoint of the product
a B is equal to the product of the
adjoint B dagger a dagger in this case
we start by writing Sai prime as equal
to a beeps I then remembering that the
product of operators is defined by first
acting on the stage
with B then we call beeps I Chi and then
we can rewrite the whole thing as a chi
now is the time to use the relation
between state space and drill space so
we write the bra site rhyme and we first
use the relation a beeps I to write it
as sy a B dagger by the definition of
the adjoint next we write again the bras
i prime but now we use the relation here
to write it down as the brachii a dagger
now we remember that Chi was defined as
beeps I so we can rewrite the brachii as
side B dagger and then we have an extra
a dagger rearranging this final
expression we obtain the BRABUS I and
then B dagger a dagger comparing the two
final expressions for the brows i prime
we see that a B dagger is indeed equal
to B dagger a dagger so that's it we set
out to investigate the properties of an
operator a and its adjoint a dagger and
we have shown that this list of
properties holds for these operators and
in particular one to remark is the fact
that the adjoint of a product of
operators reverses the order of those
operators in this video we have worked
through some mathematical properties of
the adjoint operator in order to become
familiar with manipulating operators
what next check out the videos in the
description to see what you can do now
that you can manipulate operators as a
hint you can learn about the time
evolution of quantum systems by learning
about how the energy operator features
in the drawing Euler equation if you
like the video or you would like send me
suggestions for future videos please
subscribe